TRUMP BUT THE OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT, THEY DON'T COUNT
ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: FREE SPEECH IS THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO CONTROL THE
WHITE HOUSE IN A YEAR.
THEY ARE SUPPRESSING SPEECH EVEN
ON KNITTING WEBSITE.
IT HAS MORE THAN 8 MILLION
MEMBERS.
THIS WEEK THE COMPANY BANNED
USER FROM EXPRESSING ANY SUPPORT
ARE IN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEIR POINT IS THE POSITION OF
63 MILLION AMERICAN VOTERS IS
"WHITE SUPREMACY."
EXPECT OTHER WEBSITES TO DO THE
SAME THING AND YOUR FREEDOM TO
ERODE MORE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE SMARTEST
PEOPLE IN THE BUILDING AND JOINS
US TONIGHT.
MELISA, ON YOU ON THIS WEBSITE?
>> I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
KNITTING.
BUT I CHECKED THE WHOLE THING
OUT.
IT'S ON THE FRONT OF THE
WEBSITE.
IT SAYS THIS IS DONE IN THE
SPIRIT OF INCLUSIVENESS.
THEY ARE INCLUDING PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE DOING THIS.
WE CAN'T PROVIDE A SPACE THAT IS
INCLUSIVE OF ALL AND ALLOW
SUPPORT FOR OPEN WHITE
SUPREMMESY.
IT SAYS SUPPORT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS SUPPORT FOR
WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
HALF OF AMERICA ARE NOW WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
THEY SAY YOU CAN STILL
PARTICIPATE, YOU JUST CAN'T TALK
ABOUT IT HERE.
I AM CONFUSED IT THIS POLICY.
WHAT COULD HAVE LED TO THIS?
WAS THIS A HUGE INCIDENT?
I HAVE NOT SEEN A LOT OF
CROCHETED MAGA HATS AROUND.
I CALLED AND EMAILED.
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET IN
CONTACT AND SO AS THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
THERE ARE NO QUOTES FROM THIS
COMPANY ANYWHERE.
THERE IS NO INDICATION OF ANY
INCIDENT THAT BROUGHT THIS
ABOUT.
I HOPE THIS IS NOT LIKE THE
JUSSIE SMOLLETT SITUATION WHERE
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET NATIONAL
MEDIA ATTENTION BY PUTTING UP
THIS POLICY ON THEIR WEBSITE.
THEY ARE NOT TELLING US ABOUT
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED.
I HAVE TO WONDER IF IT'S
BRILLIANT MARKETING ON.
THEIR TWITTER PAGE IT HAS A
BLACK LIVES MATTER SIGN ON THE
TOP.
MAYBE THEY KNOW THEIR CUSTOMER
WELL AND THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
AFTER.
PR, THERE YOU GO.
>> Tucker: I KNOW A LOT OF
KNITTERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHO ARE RADICAL.
POLITICIZING EVERYTHING HAS A